did Joe Biden just create a student debt
bomb after pausing payments for 3 years
and promising to wipe out their loans
College grads aren't paying them at an
alarming rate a staggering 40% of
borrowers spped out on their first bills
due in October after the pandemic pause
was lifted so why are grads refusing to
pay back their loans young borrowers
claim they don't care if their credit
gets crushed because they won't be able
to afford a home someday
anyway so what if I don't pay my student
loans what are you going to do ruin my
credit so I can't buy the house that I
wasn't even going to be able to buy ever
in my lifetime
anyways and thankfully Joe Biden isn't
the one crunching the numbers the
president bragging about relieving debt
for over 130 million Americans even
though there are only 40 million with
loans I have I went to the Supreme Court
my to eliminate student debt was out
there and guess
what Supreme Court ruled against but I
still got 136 million people's debt
relieved Dana what she talking about
well I mean I don't know I don't know
how they're counting up the numbers I
mean this is the problem of trying to
buy votes okay so he over promised and
he underd delivered the Supreme Court
said you can't do this he said right
okay got it and then the left went nuts
and he said oh wait never mind I will do
it anyway and then they sort of did a
half measure but what the young woman
was saying that you played the what that
did the Tik Tok video think this is a
real issue for young people and
candidates from both sides of the aisle
have to figure out some sort of message
for them what is the future what is the
hope there was a time when paying off
your debt was a source of Pride and
relief and you're like I did it and I
understand that they have a lot of debt
but they also have degrees and there's a
problem with the University charging way
too much I read today about how much it
costs for just room and board at these
universities because they have
apartments that are nicer than anything
I lived in for the first 10 years after
uh high school when I was in college so
I think this is also happening with the
migrants right so you promise a path to
citizenship you promise that you're not
going to do deportations you promise
that there's not going to be a problem
of you finding work in this country when
you're running for president you become
president you don't push that back no
wonder the migrants don't stop coming no
Wonder they're not going to pay their
student loans but I am concerned about
young people feeling like they are not
going to be able to make it and again
it's probably why you see in the polls
young people starting to say let me take
a look at least at the other party even
if they don't like President Trump
directly they might be able to say let
me look at something else because
clearly these last few years are not
working for them all right Harold so uh
if you look at the Tik Tock I mean these
young people are making 50,000 a year
they've got debt of 38,000 and they want
the average house is 400,000 is this
because of B
omics well first of all I I would
question the college or the college
education one receives if they've
graduated from college and one of their
first acts is to say they're not going
to pay back their college debt and then
advertise it on Tik Tok and self-promote
and then hide behind this AB absurd
notion that you don't want to pay your
debts off uh you don't care if your
credit gets crushed because you're not
going to be able to afford a home anyway
this is a young woman who has no idea
what her future holds I would hope that
she would want to work hard and play the
rules and take some chances and risk but
and that's what we should be promoting
I've said all along the student loan
forgiveness the the blanket forgiveness
was not what I would have done I
understand trying to incentivize people
are go into areas where we need more
workers we need more thinkers we need
more doers uh being in the medical field
a teaching field a law enforcement field
we've talked about truck drivers and
others I get that but just to give it to
anyone um and then to hear this young
lady uh I hope that just piece of advice
to anyone who's not going to pay their
debt back I I've tried pay my debts off
don't go on Tik Tok and say that you're
not going to pay it back because you
don't care um in any college that has
graduates that are doing that you should
send them notices saying please don't
send money back to University come back
and let us give you an economics course
because you have to pay your debt back
and the President should be saying the
same thing as well people got a big
pause and now we're asking everybody to
chip in and do their part well isn't the
president Jesse incentivizing these high
costs and the high cost of college by
you know even trying to begin to pay the
loans for these young people if I were a
conspiracy theorist yes if it's a big if
I would say they broke the bank so the
rates had to get jacked up which forces
Young Americans to move back home with
their parents so then they're not dating
and then they're not getting married and
then they're not having babies which
drives the birth rate down so Biden can
open the borders to throw up population
grow
yes if I were a conspiracy theorist but
you're not but I'm not yeah today but it
Hunter does the same thing why should
anybody pay their loan off when the son
of the president doesn't even pay his
taxes yeah I mean he's conspiring with
his son to blow off a congressional
subpoena they don't care about these
people they do whatever they want and
you know greig in the end it's it's
about a moral core I mean somebody else
should pay your bill that you contracted
to pay and the person that pays is going
to be the taxpayer who actually PID his
bills that's what always got me about
this why it was so immoral and UNC and
just wrong is that you could have done
this differently if you wanted to a
focus on practical Majors whether it's
stem or Premed science nursing
engineering but also let's say they
let's say Joe Biden had come up with a
with a plan that actually split the
burden all right let's say you're you
pay 250 bucks a month on your college
loan right the recipient for a while
pays a hundred government pays 50 the
bank pays 50 the school pays 50 how easy
it share you know share the relief but
that didn't happen and why because Joe
didn't even bother to think about it
right it didn't occur to them because
they see the American public the US
taxpayer as this vast Money Pit that you
could just scoop it out like it's an all
you can eat buffet without a without a
cover and it it really is no better than
a smash and Grabber that's how they look
at you that should drive you insane
okay hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else